Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of Holotalk for the week of January 16th, 2000.
A special broadcast this week.
It's the first time that Holotalk is being broadcast both in real audio format and also in MPEG format, which has a number of advantages because now you have the portable MPEG players that you can pick up at the electronic stores and the stereo stores.
And you can download MPEG files onto the MPEG player and then take them whenever and wherever you go to listen to the programming instead of being attached to your computer.
And they sort of work a little bit, well, actually the opposite of a digital camera, where with a digital camera you take a picture and download that picture onto your computer.
With the MPEG player, you take the MPEG audio file and upload it to the player.
Then you disconnect the player, put it in your pocket, and go wherever you want to go and listen to the file whenever you want to listen to it.
So it's a little bit of an option here for HoloTalk listeners, and uh looking forward to hearing your feedback on the new MPEG format as an option as well.
To download the MPEG file, if you have a PC, what you want to do is right-click on the link and then save the file.
And if you have a Mac, you need to option click and then save the file.
Once it's saved to your computer, you can then open it in your MPEG player or of course upload it to your portable MPEG player as well.
This week we have a little bit of a different type of broadcast, very similar to a broadcast that we did uh earlier in uh the year of last year when we did a special Holotalk broadcast in Spanish.
This one's going to be in French, and uh we have a teacher in the region here, Debbie Swann, who was kind enough to come into the studio and do some translation on an introduction to holography, a very simple introduction for uh people in France who may not be aware of holography, how it works or what it's about, just enough to just wet the appetite.
And we will take this audio file in just a short amount of time and put a special French webpage up very similar to the Spanish webpage that I have there now.
The only difference is we are going to have the French audio recording in both real audio and MPEG format, but also this time I'd like to put up several links to different holography sites in France.
So if any of the HoloTalk listeners out there know of any links to holography resources in France, whether it be companies or holographic artists or even amateur holography in France, could you send those links to me and I will make sure that they are put on the French HoloTalk page so that anyone who comes on to Holo Holo World itself, they will see that there is a special page for them in French, and they can go to that page and listen to the broadcast being translated by Debbie Swann and then have the list of resources to holography links in their country on that page.
So if you have any links, could you please send them along and I'll make sure that they're added to the page.
And also, if you're a science educator, and I know there are a lot of you out there that listen to the program at a high school or junior high school where foreign languages are taught, you may also want to mention this to your uh foreign language uh French teachers as well.
They could have their students come on and see the webpage in French, listen to the French HoloTalk, and also visit a couple uh laser and holography uh websites in France, which would be a nice supplement uh supplement to their uh education, everyday education in the classroom as well.
Okay, before we get to that, I have a few announcements.
Uh number one, uh holography night.
Well, actually, it's going to be holography day, but for the general public, it'll be holography night, at Lakewood, New Jersey on Monday evening, January 24th, 2000.
That's uh this upcoming Monday night.
At Georgian Court College, uh, I will have holograms there on exhibit, specifically holograms that have been created using the new diode lasers.
I'll be giving demonstrations of how holograms are made, including using the little shoebox holography system.
And I will also have a number of different lasers there.
We will compare the helium neon laser to the small diode lasers, and I'll have one of the DS 65825 diode laser systems there as well.
So if you'd like to come out, I would love to meet you.
That's Monday night, January 24th at Georgian Court College.
If you'd like more information, send an email to me.
I know it's exit 91 off the Garden State Parkway.
So it's an easy drive from South Jersey or the Metropolitan New York area.
Um I will send you more information like the specific time, which you think you would think I would have that marked down, but I don't have that marked down.
I have to find that out at what time the nighttime presentation will begin.
Uh send me an email.
I'll give you more information.
Love to see you out there.
Also on May 6th at the Smithsonian, Washington, D.C., I will be there throughout the day from about 11 in the morning until three or four in the afternoon.
Uh also giving demonstrations on lasers and holography, and also have a small gallery of uh excuse me, holograms on exhibit at the Hershawn Museum.
So that'll be May 6th in Washington, D.C.
at the Smithsonian, at the Hershawn Museum throughout the day.
Fun for the whole family.
So if you're in the Washington, DC area, why don't you come in and say hello and bring the family with you?
There's going to be some great holograms there for all of you to take a look at.
And on both of those dates we will have uh one or two members of the Freedlands group for career and workforce innovation who will finish out the program by letting you know both um Monday night this upcoming January 24th and also on May 6th on how you can pursue careers in lasers and holography and the photonics industry.
So that uh will be a nice supplement to the program as well to get some information on resources on especially if you're a student how you can pursue careers in these uh different fields.
So uh looking forward to see you there.
If you can make it out come up and say hello.
I'd love to meet you.
Okay, let's move on to the uh special broadcast of uh HoloTalk in French.
Uh once again I'd like to say thank you to Debbie Swann who is uh kind enough to come over and do the translations for me and uh we hope to be able to continue this trend of providing holo talk in a number of different native languages uh so that we can really get an international flair at HoloWorld uh for the field of lasers and holography.
I believe it runs about five minutes or so.
I hope you enjoy it.
Coming up next week we're going to begin a series of broadcasts which will run every week on West Coast holographers.
So you'll want to tune in to that as well.
That'll be beginning next week which will be actually January uh twenty-fourth which will be the night I'll be in New Jersey but I'll make sure I have that up uh early on Sunday so that you can access that as well.
And don't forget that we have the uh questionnaire on the uh initial holo I'm not going to come back on after the program's over, so I'll say thank you for tuning in and hope you tune in each and every week throughout the winter into the spring as Holo Talk brings you news and information and guests on the field of lasers and holography.
Take care.
See you next week.
Hello, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to a special broadcast of HoloTalk.
Bonjour et bienvenue à un production special de HoloTalk.
I'm in the studio with a translator, Debbie Swann.
You see Debbie Swann ici avec Frank Defradis.
This is the second broadcast in a series of broadcasts.
That will bring Holo Talk to other countries in their native languages.
Let's start off by asking the question, what is holography?
Holography is very similar to photography.
Except that when you look at a hologram, you see three dimensions.
With a photograph, you only have two dimensions.
For instance, if you had a photograph of an apple behind a box.
Par exemple, si vous avez une photograph d'une pomme derrière.
You would not be able to look around the box and see the apple behind it.
Because the photograph has height and width.
But does not have depth.
With a hologram, you would be able to move and look around the box.
And see the apple behind it.
Because the hologram contains height, width, and depth.
Let's examine what holography is used for.
Which stops other people from manufacturing cards.
You may actually have a hologram on a pair of jeans.
So you know that when you buy the jeans, they are made by who you think they are made from.
Don't jean, you saved the proper manufacturer, par exemple.
In medicine, holograms are used to show internal organs.
And doctors can actually go up inside and take measurements as if the organ were really there.
In commercial holography, you may find a hologram inside of a magazine.
Which shows a three-dimensional picture of the product.
In the future, you may have your favorite television show projected right into your living room.
Holograms are created using lasers.
It is only one of many uses of the laser.
Other uses include communications.
When you make a long distance telephone call, your voice travels over a laser beam.
Recently we've discovered new ways to make holograms.
If you would like more information about holography, I invite you to explore the Holo World website.
This is Frank Defradus.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
Merci beaucoup.
And enjoy your journey in learning about lasers and holography.